[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
tous
houas
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
l'agent de matt pokora calais
ce nouveau délire que j'adore c'est vrai
mr simulator ses plus hautes oeuvres à
toi mais sans rigoler ça part de là ça
arrive là sa part ici comme est lui sans
rigoler et tous les chemins mènent à la
beauté on va revenir à la grande
rigolade du show touleïev fait plaisir à
quelqu'un raté les spectateurs et
aujourd'hui on a eu une petite vidéo
d'une maman qui s'appelle alexandra ou
mais cyril bonin je suis d origine me
cacher dans ma cuisine pour pas qu'on
puisse entendre
je sais qu'avec toi tout est possible
j'ai un jeune danseur de 12 ans et demi
à la maison qui est fan et qui adore m
pokora
j'aimerais que pour mon petit jérémy tu
puisse lui faire rencontrer un beau
corps alors mat le petit jérémy il est
fou de toi il a 12 ans il fait de la
danse partout il fait que tout est dense
il connaît toutes les chorégraphies par
coeur ils écoutent en boucle tous tes
albums son rêve absolu c'est de te
rencontrer et en fait il est dans un
bureau juste à côté on l'a appelé il
pense qu'il est en train a passé un
casting pour une salsa la voile à
regarder il pense qu'il va passer un
casting
voilà pour une émission de jeunes
talents sauf que le casteur en fait
c'est un comédien à la voix et mat je
propose que tu ailles le surprendre dans
la lentille et que tu nous le ramène sur
le plateau ça fait une heure qui dansent
bon sens aux castings
c'est il s'en sort bien sage et revit
salut mon pote c'est tout ce que je n'ai
pas
[Musique]
aérez votre mur je te tiens prends ça
pour parler s'est il paraît que c'était
galère et depuis n'a non ça va j'avais
c'est la surprise totale
ouais elle est bonne ta maman est là
alors
[Applaudissements]
ça c'était c'était sa tête ça le faisait
pas partie d'un sourire ou de lui c'est
toi le mec que tu préfères au monde
ouais c'est vrai je veux lui faire un
petit bisou quoi pour toi
le taux de faire tout ça et là le dvd
collector ça tu pars avec matmat le
signer mais est ce qu'on peut se quitter
sur cette année là avec matt avec jérémy
tu connais la chorégraphie ou pas alors
je sors watts
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ah il est beau et bon
c
m
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]